Tell me why do you say you are a painter
Because I love painting I have to paint. I've always been a painter that I know
a born painter
Yes
how do you know
Because I can't do anything else, an believe me I've tried
I think myself as an exile
You're Vincent, Theo's brother? yes , brother. I'm Paul Gauguin
You have to start a revolution. Do you understand? We have to create a new vision a new way of painting
I spent all my life alone in a room. I'd like to find a new light
for paintings that we haven't yet seen
There's something inside me, I don't know what it is
What I see nobody else sees
You're stranger here. You drink too much you'er hysterical and go out of control. I don't want to calm down
It's called the act painting for a reason
LEAVE ME ALONE
GO AWAY
Don't you see that this painting is unpleasant your townspeople has signed a petition against you they don't want you to come back
I can't stay here Vincent. You're surrounded by stupid wicked ignorant people
So that's the reason why you got off your ear, your vision of the world is quite frightening, isn't it? Yes
Sometimes I feel so far away from everything I think I'm losing my mind
Sometimes they say I'm mad but a grain of madness is the best of art
Can you believe that God gave you the gift of painting to keep you in misery? I never thought about it that way
Maybe God made me a painter for people who aren't born yet
Tell me brother am I a good painter? Not a good painter Vincent. You're a great painter
I wanted so much to share what I see
Now I just think about my relationship to eternity
You